[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIC IGLESIAS: All Right.
Howdy, everyone.
Hopefully you're all here to
see Continuous Delivery Best
Practices with Jenkins and GKE.
My name is Vic Iglesias.
I'm a solutions
architect with Google.
My Twitter handle
is there if you
want to heckle me digitally.
I am a huge fan of
Jenkins, and I've
been using Jenkins for somewhere
on the order of five or six
years now.
I've broken Jenkins
a lot, have made
Jenkins do some things that
Jenkins did not want to do.
And in that, I've
learned some things.
And then, I joined
Google, and I'm
kind of the guy who makes
these best practices
kind of documentations
for Jenkins at Google.
My coworkers have
picked up on this,
and they have created a
set of memes about how much
I love Jenkins, like this one.
"Yo dawg, I heard
you like Jenkins,
so I wrote a Jenkins plugin to
launch Jenkins pods to monitor
all your Jenkins jobs."
They continually come out
with these heckling me
about all of my
Jenkins solutions
and how much I love Jenkins.
So today, we're going to do
a brief overview of Jenkins.
How many people use Jenkins?
Yeah.
I usually get about
a 50%, but I'd
figure they'd be more
like 80% or 90% here.
How many Jenkins on GCP?
All right.
And how about on GKE?
OK, cool.
So we'll do a brief overview.
Most you guys know what
we're talking about here.
Then, we're going to talk
about the Jenkins journey.
I'm sure we've all been
here before, where you start
in one place and you end up
molding a Jenkins installation
over time.
And we're going to talk
about what that looks like.
And then, we're
going to about how
to implement the end state--
when you've gotten Jenkins in
a good state and it's scalable
and it runs well and
your team is happy.
Once we go through
that, we'll talk
about how to integrate
Jenkins and Spinnaker in order
to do continuous delivery.
All right.
So a brief overview.
What is Jenkins, this Jenkins
guy we've been talking about?
It's a build server.
You can trigger or
schedule jobs or processes
and run your automation steps.
At some point, somebody
has scripted something,
and they want to run it
in a shared environment
or run it on every commit.
Jenkins gives you a really
easy way to do that.
We also have a
pluggable architecture,
which is a lot of the
reason why Jenkins
is used by a lot of
the folks in this room.
It can capture a lot of
the use cases that we have
and various tools that we need
to integrate into our CI and CD
processes.
How many people use
Jenkins plugins?
How many people use more
than five Jenkins plugins?
More than 10?
20?
Ooh.
All right.
We should talk after.
The Jenkins plugin ecosystem is
what enables us to use Jenkins,
but also has its downsides.
You have to keep
track of the plugins.
They are mostly open source.
You have to know the
quality of the plugin.
It has to have
good documentation.
It has to have a good
upgrade strategy.
So with every blessing,
there is a little bit
of a curse in these plugins.
One of the nice things about
Jenkins is it runs on the JVM
and so does its agent,
so we can register nodes
on various distros.
So you can have Linux agents--
which is what mostly I've used
in the past--
Windows agents, or Mac agents.
How many people are using
Windows or Mac with Jenkins?
Yeah.
Cool.
So that's what we're
talking about here.
So when someone asked me, what
do I do for my CI/CD process?
I just sprinkle a
little Jenkins on it.
That's not always the case,
but a lot of the times
we can start there.
So what does a Jenkins
journey look like?
Well, day one, genesis.
People have been running
scripts on their computers.
There's some scripts
that are clobbering
each other's behaviors,
and you decide
that you need a shared
place to run these based off
of get commits, which would be
a really nice way to do things.
So you find a machine somewhere.
It's probably in the corner.
It's like a Raspberry Pi.
And you install Java on it.
It takes up all the memory.
You install Jenkins.
You load up all your
dependencies on there,
whatever you need
for your build.
You might need a special
version of Node or Go
or some test library
or something like that.
And then, you start
running your scripts
in this shared build server.
So you're stoked.
It's better than everybody
else running in their laptops.
And what you end up with is this
one Jenkins master node that
has the Jenkins JVM process
in there, a build executer--
that's a process that's
actually running your builds--
and all your build
dependencies in there.
Additionally, you have the
Jenkins home file system.
How many people are
familiar with Jenkins home?
It's really comfortable.
It's our home.
So in your home, you
have your configuration,
and that's the configuration
of all your plugins,
of your Jenkins server itself.
You also have built artifacts--
so things that you're storing
after you're build completes.
That might be some sort of
binary or things like that.
The other thing that
runs in that Jenkins home
is your build workspaces.
So your build workspaces is that
scratch space that your build
gets to, clone your repo, and
do temporary things in that
build process.
So you're stoked.
People are sharing
in this environment.
They're triggering builds off
of commits or scheduling builds.
But then, you see this, right?
How many people have
seen this Jenkins?
Yeah.
It's painful.
So something has gone wrong
in your Jenkins installation.
It may not be scaling
appropriately.
Maybe you ran out of resources
on that Raspberry Pi.
So what do you do?
You scale two more nodes.
So you take your build
agents, and you run them
somewhere else.
So your builds run separately.
This is great.
You've moved your build executer
process out of your Jenkins
master.
You've moved your
build dependencies
into those Jenkins nodes
and your build workspaces.
So now you're Jenkins master
has some room to breathe.
So this is a great next
step, having a static fleet
distributed from
your Jenkins master.
But again, the
build is breaking.
And this time, it is
because we need more disk.
Those build artifacts that
were on our Jenkins master
have filled up our
Jenkins home file system.
So now, we decide to
start using object storage
to move our artifacts off
of that Jenkins master.
I think you should
probably use Google Cloud
Storage for reasons I
won't tell you about,
but you think you want
all of this storage
to move to any other place
other than your Jenkins masters,
and there's various plugins
that can make this happen.
How many people are
using an artifact plugin?
OK.
So now, you're happy.
You're scaling well.
Jenkins master is
healthy and happy.
But your developers
are coming to you
and saying that
they need competing
versions of dependencies
on these build agents.
So now, you've got the
problem of figuring out,
how do I label these nodes?
How do I get people to
run the write builds
on the right systems?
But instead, you decide to
move to containerization.
So you can run each of
your builds in containers,
and you get the benefit of
being able to give developers
exactly the dependencies
that they want,
and you won't clobber
each other's dependencies.
So now, developers are happy.
They have more control.
Next, they come to you
with the next problem.
Yes, we have more control.
This is great.
But we're poking
around the Jenkins UI
too much in order to
configure our jobs.
So we want a way to do
this in source code,
and the way to do
this and Jenkins
is using the Jenkins
pipeline plugin
and creating your Jenkins
file next to your source code.
So now, developers
can commit code
that changes the test
process or the build process
and the source code at the same
time, and they're really happy.
How many people are
using Jenkins pipeline?
Yes.
We should get that to
everyone relatively soon.
So that's great.
And you put
pipelines everywhere.
You can have your happy little
pipeline world in Jenkins land,
and everybody is happier that
they have control over their
build process.
Next, your CFO comes
up to you and says,
hey, you know, it's
looking like we're
spending quite a bit of
money on this CI process.
Do you think you could
tune that down in any way?
So you poke around and you
realize, oh, I know what to do.
Between 8:00 and 6:00, I
have a lot of builds running.
But as soon as developers
leave and go home,
there's no builds running
on all my build agents.
So you look into some way
to do autoscaling agents so
that, when you kick off a build
and there's no agent available,
it's provisioned for you, has
all your dependencies in there.
And then, when no builds are
running, it terminates itself.
And there are various
ways to do this.
There is a GCE plugin that
allows you to do this with VMs.
You can also use Kubernetes
plugin to do this on GKE,
and we'll talk a little
bit more about that.
Great.
So you're moving along at
a pretty good clip here.
Now, day 412 comes
along, and each team
is competing for which
plugins are the right plugins
to have in their
Jenkins installation.
Not every plugin is compatible
with every other plugin.
There is a dependency
chain there.
So they say, we want to have
our own Jenkins installations
for our team or for
our sets of teams.
So you figure out a way to
make reproducible Jenkins
installations and give them
exactly the plugins that they
want.
So you've made
everybody really happy.
You have a scalable system.
Now, you're managing
multiple Jenkins,
but since they autoscale and
they have enough resources
and don't overprovision
resources for them,
you're feeling good
as an administrator.
OK.
So that was what you need to
do to be happy with Jenkins
at scale, but how do
you get there today?
First, you have to figure
out how to deploy Jenkins.
And in the previous
slide, I showed
using Helm to deploy Jenkins.
One of the nice things--
how many people
know what Helm is?
Get them out.
So I'll talk a little
bit about Helm.
Helm is a package
manager for Kubernetes.
It allows you to package up
applications and then install
them.
The packages in this
context are called charts,
and charts are ways to define
what comes with an application.
There is a Jenkins home
chart in the community,
and it provides a lot
of the same defaults
that you would expect for
a Jenkins installation
to be scalable and secure.
So we leverage this
in order to create
our installations of Jenkins.
One of the nice things
about this Helm chart
is it allows you to
define declaratively
exactly the plugins
you want to have
in your installation,
which is super useful.
So what does this look like?
On the left here, we have
the installation command
for Jenkins--
helm install stable/jenkins
and then a values file.
Stable is the name of
the chart repository
that this chart is coming from.
Jenkins is obviously
the name of the chart
that we're installing.
And then, I pass it
this values file,
and this is my configuration.
On the right here, you
can see the configuration
that I'm passing it.
I have a list plugins.
I have some CPU and
memory configuration.
And I have some job ops.
Who knows what people are
going to throw in there,
but that always comes up.
The next thing I do is I disable
the default agent configuration
because I want my developers
in their Jenkins files
to define this.
And I'll show how this
is possible later.
The next few are
the persistence,
the size of the Jenkins home.
Again, I don't need
a huge disk, but I
like to have some space
in there for Jenkins
to have its configurations
and so forth.
And the other two options,
the NetworkPolicy and the rbac
are some security defaults that
you can get out of the box.
Cool.
So what do I get by
installing this Helm
chart into a Kubernetes
engine cluster?
First, you can use Kubernetes
engine's autoscaling node
pools, which allows you
to provision new pods,
and Kubernetes engine
will add new nodes
to your cluster as needed.
Next, we get into that
world automatically where
we have all of our build
dependencies defined
by containers-- that is, just
the default mode that you're
going to use when you're
running on Kubernetes engine.
The next thing you get
is ephemeral workspaces,
and this is something that
was really important when
I was running CI systems
a few years ago is
to have a clean workspace
for every build.
So this is going to
be guaranteed for you
because your docker container is
going to come up, do its work,
and then that workspace is
going to be cleared out.
So you don't have any cruft
coming in from other builds.
The next thing you can
have is pre-emptable nodes.
Pre-emptable nodes
allow you to save
70% of the cost of your nodes,
but there is a trade-off.
At any point, those nodes could
be deprovisioned or terminated,
and they will only
last up to 24 hours.
So if you have some builds
that can be restarted,
this can save you quite a
bit of money out of the gate.
What we see is customers
running half of their nodes
as pre-emptable and another
half as regular nodes
so that they can always
have capacity for builds.
The next thing that running
on Kubernetes engine
gives you is the ability to
apply soft and hard resource
limits.
So if I say that a build needs
at least a gigabyte of RAM,
I can say that it also cannot
use more than two gigs of RAM.
So I can set specifically how
much resources these builds
are going to use as
they share a node.
Cool.
So how do I define these
agents in my Jenkins file?
And this is something
that I advocate
for because you're giving that
control over to the developer.
You're saying, you
tell me how you
want your build spec to look.
You have various containers
that you can run in here.
And as you can see here, I'm
just defining a Kubernetes pod.
That means that I can
define multiple containers
if I need them and separate my
build dependencies in that way.
And that's really useful.
The other thing that I'm doing
down here is wrapping my shell
commands-- in this
example, go test--
with the container markup here.
And that allows me to
say which container
each of these commands
should run in.
So really, you've
handed over all
of the control of
the build process
to the developer in source
code, which is really awesome.
So now that we've given them
control over their environment
and the build dependencies
that are in there,
we have to give them a way to
actually build those images.
The easiest way to
do that would be
to use Google Cloud
build, which allows
you to create a trigger
based off of source code.
Then we'll build your
image and then upload that
to Google Container Registry.
So a really streamlined process
for them to change their
build dependencies.
Next, we said we want to
leave our artifacts off
of the Jenkins master.
So we're going to install the
Google Cloud Storage plugin.
We're going to upload a
GCP IAM service account
key that has access
to the projects
that we want to upload
our artifacts to.
And then, we're going
to use those in our
build process, usually
as opposed to build step,
to upload our artifacts
to Google Cloud Storage.
This can be done in the UI
or also as a pipeline step.
Cool.
So now, let's get into
the demo side of that,
and we're going to demo a
developer updating their image
and then pushing
a new build out.
All right.
So if we could go over
to the demo laptop,
yes, I am running
Linux on the desktop.
Yes, it was extremely
difficult to get
this to show up on the screen.
All right.
So let's go to some code here.
So this is my developer
test image here.
And really, it's just a
Docker file that has golang
and a couple of my
dependencies in there.
Great.
So let's say that I wanted to
use the golang rc build from
golang 1.11 instead of 1.10.
I'm going to go ahead
and commit that.
All right.
Golang 1.11.
I'm going to tag it and push
that tag and the commit.
So when I push
this, Cloud Build is
going to detect that I've
created a new commit,
and it's going to start
building my artifact.
Great.
So really, I didn't
have to do much in order
to make that happen.
I could basically ignore the
fact that it did happen at all
and just start adding that
configuration of that base
image to my Jenkins file.
So in my Jenkins
file for my app,
I am defining the pod that
I want to run for my build.
And in here, I have my test
image that I just showed you,
and I'm going to change
from version 6.0 to 7.0,
which is the one I
just built. And that's
really all I wanted to
change at this point.
So now, as a
developer, I can change
my build setup relatively easy.
And I'll just make that
change to my pipeline file
and commit and push that.
Cool.
All right.
And once I push that, it's
going to go ahead and be
detected by Jenkins.
I'm actually just going to
kick a build off myself.
Whoops.
Demo time.
Let's see this here.
Ahh, my port forwarding
wasn't working.
Let's see.
So let's kick that off again.
All right.
And so now I've got my build
running inside of Jenkins,
and let's see what
this Jenkins file does.
In here, I have
my pod definition.
I'm defining two containers--
one for my test image,
and that's just really for
running gotest, and then
one for gcloud.
And so, I don't have to
have this one mega uber
image for every single
thing that I want to have.
I can compartmentalize
these dependencies
and then use them independently.
And Jenkins is going to
mount my workspace into each
of these containers,
so I don't have
to worry about
moving or mounting
weird workspaces anywhere.
So in my test
image, I run gotest.
And then, after it's done
and the tests have passed--
which I'm sure were
really good tests--
I'm going to just run gcloud
container build submit in order
to build an image
from my docker file.
So let's take a look at
what's going on here.
So here, my build started.
We can see my
commit message here.
Jenkins provisioned a pod
for me and then started
running my tests
and then the build.
So if I look in my
Kubernetes commands,
I can see that my
test pod was created.
So that's great.
And now, it's being terminated
once the build has completed.
And that's because we had
our image built and pushed.
So our new image has been
deployed, and we're happy.
Cool.
So that's the process of
a developer kind of owning
that CI process for themselves.
So let's go back to the slides,
and we'll keep moving along.
So we talked about the CI
part of Jenkins on GKE.
Now, we'll talking about
CD, Continuous Delivery
or Continuous Deployment.
This is going to be
your best friend.
This is kind of the
best tool we have today
and what we're going to
use throughout this demo
to talk about how to deploy
to Kubernetes from Jenkins.
How many people are using
kubectl apply to deploy?
Yeah.
OK.
So the first thing you're
going to ask when you're
using a kubectl apply
or anything like this
is, which cluster should
I be deploying to?
And in order to
understand that, we first
should understand
how kubeconfig works.
So the kubeconfig defines
a bunch of clusters,
and that's a name, a server
URL, and some CA data.
It also defines some users
and ways to authenticate
to those clusters.
And it combines those two things
into what's called a context,
and the context is what
tells us definitively
who we should authenticate
with and which
cluster to authenticate to.
Within your kubeconfig,
you're going
to have multiple of
these contexts lined up,
and one of them is
going to be flagged
as your current context.
That's going to be
the default context
that when you run kubectl
with no other flags
is going to be used.
Cool.
So now that we know
that, how do we
use kubeconfig
inside of Jenkins?
Well, they have a
handy plugin, again,
called the Kubernetes
CLI plugin.
So in order to use
this, we're going
to upload our kubeconfig as
a Jenkins administrator--
as a Jenkins credential.
And then, within
our pipelines, we
can use that Jenkins credential
with this withKubeConfig
wrapping block
around our commands.
So that is what sets the context
for each of these commands
that we run in that block.
So here, I have two
different stages,
one that deploys to canary,
one that applies to production.
And I can choose
which cluster it
is by setting the context name
in each of those withConfig
blocks.
So now that we know
where to deploy code to,
how do we know how
to roll out the code?
So for example, we could
do a blue-green deployment.
How many folks do
blue-green deployments?
Some?
OK.
So blue-green deployment
in Kubernetes,
without bringing
Jenkins into the mix,
you would have a service
and a deployment,
and that service would map
to the deployment based
on the labels.
So here, I have a label
app and a label version,
and those apply
to my deployment.
So now, it's sending
traffic to the blue version.
In order to bring
on my green version,
I would deploy it with a
different set of labels.
So here, I have
app my-app still,
but I've changed the
version to green.
So the service is no longer
mapping to that deployment.
But when I do want to map
it to that deployment,
I can switch the
label on the service
and do a blue-green
deployment that way.
Now, if I want to
switch back, I just
can switch the labels
on the service.
So that makes it easy to
do blue-green and then
roll back quickly.
All right.
So we talked about
Jenkins there.
What would this look
like in a pipeline?
Well, first, we would
want to build an image.
You get an artifact out there.
Then, we want to create a
new deployment, which there
are many ways to do set and grep
and awk and all kinds of things
to get the right build
image into your deployment.
And once we do deploy
that new deployment,
we want to make sure
we verify it somehow.
And what does that mean?
Well, some things you could
do-- there's probably more--
is check that the rollout
has actually completed.
So you can use the kubectl
rollout status deployment
command, and that
will tell you, yes, I
think that I have
done everything
that I need to do in
order to make sure
that this deployment rolls out.
The next thing you
can do is check
that all your pods are
healthy and running
for some period of time after.
So you might run
into a situation
where you've
deployed a deployment
and the pods come up
healthy but then crash
after some amount of time.
So you might want to decide how
long that real healthy period
is going to be for you.
And you can also define
some of this stuff inside
of the Kubernetes manifest.
Cool.
So now, we've verified
that our deployment has
succeeded as far as we know.
Now, we can shift traffic to
it using a similar mechanism.
And then, again,
we're going to verify
that, once we switch traffic
over, our service is happy.
So how are we going to do this?
We can use kubectl
endpoints to make sure
that pods are actually
mapped to our service.
And this would be
something to verify
that your labeling
scheme is correct.
You may have put some bad
labels in that deployment,
and now your service doesn't
know where to send traffic.
The next thing you can
do is go one level up
on the load balancing side.
And if you've had any HTTP
load balancers provisioned
with an ingress
resource, you can
use kubectl get ingress to make
sure your backends are still
healthy.
Once those are
complete and you know
your service is mapped to a
load balancer appropriately,
you can start to run tests.
Maybe it's kubectl run.
Maybe you're hitting
it from outside.
But actually verify
that your service
is doing what it's supposed
to be doing in some way,
shape, or form.
If these things fail,
you can roll back
to the previous
deployment at this point.
If everything succeeds, then you
delete your previous deployment
and move along your merry way.
So that's one way to
deploy, which is blue-green.
How many people
do rolling update?
A good majority.
Your application has to be
understanding of a rolling
update, but it's a great way
to deploy and the default way
to deploy within Kubernetes.
We will bring up
new pods for you
and tear down your
old ones one by one.
You do have some flexibility
in how you roll out
when you do that strategy,
and your options here
are how many pods should I
should you bring up at a time,
and then how many pods can be
unavailable at any given time.
These two can be used
with either percentages
or absolute values.
And I think, for
larger deployments,
you're going to want
to do percentages.
For things that are
relatively static,
you might be able
to just get away
with using a number of pods.
Cool.
So what can I do further to
make this deployment robust?
One thing is the readiness
and liveness probes
that you attach to your pods.
How many people use
readiness probes?
This is probably the
most important thing
you can do to have a
robust deployment process.
What is a readiness probe?
The readiness probe is
a way for Kubernetes
to ask your app if it
should send traffic to it.
And that's a really key place.
It's where your application
and the infrastructure meet,
and you have to
have something that
is very indicative of your
service's health responding
here.
So for example, you can
have an HTTP request.
Some people have
a health endpoint.
You can have all kinds
of different things
that are checked
in this endpoint.
And if, for example,
your application
needs to reach
out to a database,
make sure that that
database is there
before you respond that you're
ready to receive traffic.
So you can think of all of
the different dependencies
in your application that
would need to be there
for you to have a really healthy
request or a healthy response
to a request that came in.
This is really something really
important to think about,
and there's a lot
of tuning you can
do to get the right
readiness probe in place.
The next thing is
graceful termination.
So when your pod is going to
get taken down by Kubernetes,
it's going to send your
pod and your containers
a SIGTERM signal, and you
have to react to that signal
because it's basically
Kubernetes-- again,
the application and
infrastructure-- coming
together to say, I am
going to tear you down.
You need to stop doing
what you're doing
and make sure that all
your requests get flushed,
for example.
So one example of a good way
to handle the SIGTERM, when
you receive that SIGTERM,
make sure that you turn off
or disable your readiness
probe so that Kubernetes
stops sending you traffic.
If you're going to be
torn down, you probably
shouldn't have any more
traffic coming at you.
After that point, you
can start to finish up
any connections
you have and then
terminate yourself gracefully.
One of the options
you have here is
the
terminationGracePeriodSeconds,
and that's going to allow you
to define how long of time
you need in order to tear down.
Great.
So we've talked about a
lot of different things
that you can do
in your CD process
using Jenkins and kubectl
apply in your pipeline files.
And now, we'll look at
a different approach,
which is using Spinnaker.
Spinnaker is a multi-cloud
continuous delivery platform.
Jenkins started
out as a CI server.
It can run anything
that you need it to run.
Spinnaker started
out as fully focused
on continuous
delivery-- only how
to get code and artifact
from one place to another.
So if continuous delivery is
this long chain of events,
Jenkins is extremely
good at this part
and Spinnaker is extremely
good at the next part, which
is actually getting
your code rolled out
into various environments,
doing manual judgments based
on whether certain metrics
are looking correct.
And so this is what
we're going to see today.
There are some interfaces
between Jenkins and Spinnaker,
and the two main ones are
that Spinnaker pipelines can
be triggered by a Jenkins job.
So as a Jenkins job
completes successfully,
Spinnaker will check
it and potentially
take some information
from that build result
and then start its pipeline
with that information.
The other thing that you can
do with Spinnaker and Jenkins
is have Spinnaker
run a Jenkins job
in the middle of a pipeline.
So you may have
a rollout process
that requires some sort of
performance test in the middle,
and that really is
orchestrated or run by Jenkins.
So you can have Spinnaker do
a rollout of a deployment,
run your integration test
or your performance test
using Jenkins, and then
continue your rollout.
So you don't always have to
pick all of them up all at once.
So in Spinnaker,
you have the ability
to define these triggers,
and the pipeline
trigger UI looks like this.
You define which Jenkins
master you want to point at,
which job you want to detect
a change in from that Jenkins
master, and then potentially
a properties file.
And so the properties file is a
way to communicate information
from Jenkins into
Spinnaker, and that
follows the Java properties
file format, which is key
equals value.
And so you can pass-- if you
create this file inside of your
build process and
archive it, then
Spinnaker can pick it up
and use this information
in its pipeline to
configure various steps.
The other thing that I said
that Spinnaker could do
is kick off a Jenkins job
in the middle of a pipeline.
So the way that this
looks is, let's say
I have a Jenkins job that
has these parameters.
In Spinnaker, as
part of my pipeline,
I can create a stage that
will pull in this Jenkins job
and show me those parameters.
It will bring up the
defaults as well.
But then, I can parametrize
them with information
from my Spinnaker pipeline.
So these two
interplay pretty well,
and so you don't have to
give up Jenkins in order
to use Spinnaker or vice versa.
So now, we'll go through
what this process actually
looks like end-to-end, with
Jenkins doing most of the CI
work and then Spinnaker
picking up from there
once an artifact is built.
So if we could switch over
to the laptop, once I log in.
OK.
So here, I mentioned, I
had a web app, sample app.
Here, we're going to do a
green-blue deployment just
to be a little different.
Our UI is green.
Some product manager comes
in with their hair on fire
and says green is no longer in.
We need this to be blue ASAP.
Developer, make it happen.
So I use my awesome coding
skills to hack HTML.
And I go to my green, change
that to blue wherever I see it.
And I am pumped.
I don't know what this error is.
We're going to ignore it.
That may be my downfall
on this whole demo thing,
but we'll see.
All right.
So I commit this, make it
blue, and I'm going to push it.
And then, we're going to
follow this along a little bit
as it goes through our process.
So again, I'm just
going to kick this off.
So we get a build ASAP.
Awesome.
So first thing that's
going to happen
is Jenkins says,
hey, I don't have
any pods available for you.
I need to provision one.
So we should see in here
that Jenkins is going
to start provisioning me a pod.
Cool.
So it provisions me a
pod just for that build.
And it's going to run through
our procedure, which is, again,
to run our tests--
well, first check out our
source code, then run our tests,
and then do a build
with Cloud Build.
And then, in Cloud
Build, I'll just show you
the trigger that I set up.
Oh, I don't have a trigger.
I'm just building them directly.
In Spinnaker, I
have a trigger here
that is waiting
for changes to GCR.
So any image that comes in into
a particular GCR repository,
it's going to kick
off this pipeline.
And then, I tell
it that I'm going
to use that docker
image that got pushed
as part of a pipeline step.
So in that pipeline, I deploy my
backend and deploy my frontend.
Right now, I have a static
artifact, which I just
enter text, but I could pull
this from a repository or a GCS
bucket.
And I tell it that
I want to take
these artifacts,
or this manifest,
and replace this image that's
in here with the one that
came in from the docker build.
So here, I have
my builds running.
And you'll see in
here that Spinnaker
is doing a lot of those
things that we scripted out
in our pipeline for us.
It's monitoring the deployment.
It's making sure that things
actually get to the state
that they want to get to.
Spinnaker actually understands
the infrastructure behind it.
So it knows what a pod is
and what it means for the pod
to be healthy and so forth.
So that's what's running
in the background here.
There we go.
So now, it's succeeded.
It's actually pushed
out our change,
and we should have blue.
And that error didn't
mean anything, so yay.
So if we could go
back to slides,
that's a very simplified view
of something you could do.
Spinnaker can do much
more complex deployments
to multiple clusters, do manual
judgments, all kinds of stuff,
but I just wanted you to
see the connective tissue
between these pieces.
And you can extrapolate
forward with your imagination
as to what your build
process should be
and your deployment
process should be.
OK, Vic.
So you just gave me
all this information.
You're probably going to
launch this on YouTube
again to probably dig
into some of the pieces,
but what can you
do today to start
getting your hands dirty
with some of these processes?
I mentioned earlier that I've
written a lot about Jenkins
and GKE, and so I'll show
you a few of the things
that I've written.
First was the Jenkins on GKE
Continuous Delivery tutorial,
and this is really
using multiple branches
to define environments
and then having
Jenkins push those environments
out into Container Engine.
And that is available
online there.
That's Jenkins on GKE
Continuous Delivery.
I also wrote one with just
Container Builder, or Cloud
Build, as it's been
renamed, and that
is Continuous Delivery with
Spinnaker on Kubernetes Engine.
So that's if you want to use
Spinnaker and Cloud Build
for your CI and CD process.
But then, there are
some folks who are not
ready to adopt Kubernetes yet.
And for those folks, I have
the Jenkins on GCE tutorial.
And this is, I think,
the easiest way
to get going with
those build agents
that I said before that
automatically autoscale and get
provisioned when you need them.
You can just basically take your
even on-prem Jenkins master,
enable the Jenkins GCE
plugin, and get going
with distributed builds on GCE.
So a really easy way to onboard.
And that is it.
Thank you so much
for listening to me.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]